you just said there is no wall high
enough
and no ocean wide enough to protect us
from the virus
so what is the thinking behind letting
untested
and unvaccinated migrants cross the
southern border
into u.s cities in record numbers
there is what we're doing we have not
withdrawn
the order that is sometimes critical or
criticized saying that unvaccinated
people
should be go back across the border but
unaccompanied children is a different
story
because there's that's the most humane
thing to do
is to test them and to treat them and
not send them back alone
right exactly an excellent question that
the president did not answer
instead he said uh i didn't rescind and
what he was talking about is title 42
which means
that all those people under that bridge
down in texas if you got
a coronavirus or or anything we can turn
you around
because the cdc this past week said okay
because we're going to go ahead and
reinstitute it keep it going
he made it sound like because of title
42 we're turning everybody
around except kids and that is an
absolute
misrepresentation of what is going on it
was a complete the
deflection because he knows the american
people are compassionate about the kids
we don't want them to be harmed in the
process but it's not just kids coming
across the border it's families
it's willing and able-bodied men coming
across the border right
and a lot of them have covert there's
crime uh
and what we know so far from our sources
and and the drone footage that we
continue to show
every single day that these people are
being processed they're being put on the
bus
um they some get a court date some don't
even get a court date and
even when they get that court date it is
years away but they are being released
back into the country they're not
notifying the states or the local
municipalities about that
and a lot of them have cultures where
are the democrats in all of this though
if their biggest concern
is covet and the spread of covet and
wearing masks mass mandates and vaccines
why aren't they outraged about this
because they're if
if they all have coveted and they bring
it into our country we're facing another
lockdown we're facing more
deaths you know during his comments
yesterday the president said and i want
to say it was the state
of vermont he said they've got one of
the highest vaccination rates
and they only had like six uh covet
cases
in a day which is a a fantastic number
but here's the thing how many people
with covid is the federal government
letting in across our southern border
each day we don't
know because the border patrol does not
test people and then you got the
the getaways they're people who just
race for
omaha and you know nobody's able to
track them
and here's the double standard too
president biden was criticizing
the governor of texas governor abbott
for the increase in covet cases
and desantis and desantis while letting
them release it in those states walk
right into their state
i mean the hypocrisy is just
overwhelming
but the bottom line is that the biden
administration isn't doing their job
they have an open borders policy
catch and release is back on the books
again and that led
cayley mcinerney one of our colleagues
to slam up the czar
come on kamala harris where has she been
what is she doing to secure the border
is she really the sars who's running the
show take a look
he's absent she is unserious about this
task of being the borders are it's why
it took her nearly a hundred days
to actually go to the border and when
she got there ainsley
she stood up and said we've made great
progress
how can you say that when there is a
21-year high
in encounters at the border a record
high as you note for the month of july
with unaccompanied minors this is a
disaster
and then she laughs about it she says
well i haven't been to europe when asked
about going to the border
she is failing at this task it's why she
has the lowest approval rating
of any vice president in the last half
century
the democrat that has been vocal about
this is henry cuellar and he is saying
that they need to appoint
jay johnson to do the job he is not a
part of administration but he was known
to
to enforce the laws that are on the
books but may york is with the deputy
under jay johnson he knows what to do
the administration is just refusing to
do it sure and one of the things they're
going to start doing here in new york
city and lawrence went out and about if
you missed a six o'clock hour you miss a
lot
uh where you talk to the people about it
sounds like mayor de blasio they're
going to start in a couple of weeks
they're going to
demand require if you want to go indoors
to a restaurant or a theater or a
sporting event or a museum or any of
those things a gymnasium
you're going to have to prove you have
been vaccinated it's not one of those
things where you get to wear a mask if
you're unvaccinated
you have to get a vaccination otherwise
you're going to be
kept out from indoors new york city
different standard at the border though
so apparently we should all just migrate
to the border
hey